i got a question you got to watch this
you got to watch the video though and
why why i thought it was real yeah sure
no i do
i got a question the black guy in the
hood entering taekwondo tournaments
i know i don't know so back in the
afternoon since you guys are a little
young to remember this boxing versus
wings
in the 80s that was a thing there was
there were all those
and all those martial arts best of the
best yeah all that sport so
a lot of people a lot of the they're
they're going down now that's
go down scroll down the third one chin
how the guy with the grade no no
yes that one now give him sucks to load
the tabs the tabs are loading them
okay so that that's the one somewhere in
channel 5 i watched that video
watch watch him though that's a that's a
legit block
watch you see you'll see why i thought
it was real this one
some of these guys are fighters just
because you're wing chun doesn't mean
you haven't punched people in the face
and i thought this would listen to this
that's him there
uh yeah but watch but wow that guy's
[ __ ] serious and you can see how i
thought it was real
look at his intensity thing what do you
mean by that um well i mean oh he's in
english
yeah he's english where are they really
doing this this is the first
to be broken and then you can't grab no
more titty then you definitely need a
pair of gloves one just test that see
what you mean so i guarantee this guy's
head on the train good so this is real
yeah but i guarantee he's had other
training he looks sure i could already
tell he's boxed
him see how he stopped that boxer that's
[ __ ] huge
he's not really trying to hit him it's
not real
here's the thing about here's the thing
about me i didn't read the comments i
was just like [ __ ] this video
i don't need her and i would i don't
need to really so then i started reading
the comments
and everybody was saying [ __ ] that you
guys would say yeah because we're not
stupid
but i was like i'm sitting here like yo
this [ __ ] dude i'm sure that's a
tough
dude dude i remember when i first saw
the video
this is like a tutorial dude this is
just him [ __ ] around like showing him
yeah yeah that's not gonna work i mean
you see does something that's not gonna
block like they'll block they do that
muay thai [ __ ] where they roll their
shoulder you'll see that sometimes you
know
but but like i don't think this is gonna
yeah you know you watch guys in the ufc
hit each other like bang like now they
don't know that i've been watching
ufc like i forced them to watch ufc 2 or
263. like you watch you watch
you watch nate diaz take those shots
yeah he's rolling he's boxing so he's
rolling with those shots he gets hit but
he
he moves with the shots he keeps his
shoulder up so there's no way that can
stop a boxer it's not that
it's not that it's not that he couldn't
block a couple of shots maybe like
he's got his elbows up in his pocket
right now he's not taking a leon edwards
jab and going
yeah right there's just no way that
could happen no
listen when i first started maybe he's
like flingling his arms i'm telling you
it's like this like if i may it's like i
don't think fighting stops at those two
punches right
like the guy goes pop up and then leon
edwards gets blocked and he he readjusts
yeah it's like so with with muay thai so
i back kick you can do a taekwondo
backhand it's actually something that
people you can catch people with
yeah a couple times what happens is then
they readjust and they go i see what
you're doing
and they take that away but the fight
keeps going there it's it's not it's not
it doesn't stop there it's like that
yeah you know what i mean
you don't go ah it's just different